[Musik]
wut auf lukaschenko zehntausende
demonstranten in belarus lassen sich
auch von massenverhaftungen nicht
abschrecken
rassismus fälle bei der polizei eine
studie um das ausmaß festzustellen lehnt
innenminister seehofer weiter ab angst
vor einem zweiten lockdown mit immer
schärferen maßnahmen kämpft
großbritannien gegen steigende corona
zahlen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch rudi cerne für den sport hallo
geplant unerschrocken protestieren sie
gegen europas letzten diktator wie sie
präsident lukaschenko nennen
auch heute waren wieder zehntausende in
belarus auf der straße seit sechs wochen
nun lassen sie sich nicht einschüchtern
obwohl die polizei immer rabiater
vorgeht gegen männer wie frauen für
begann die schlagstöcke geben den
rhythmus vor
da diese drohkulisse die protestierenden
nicht abschreckt wird schwereres gerät
vorgefahren friedlich demonstrierende
die mit fahnen und plakaten faire
neuwahlen fordern treffen auf maskierte
uniformierte bewaffnete in ganz belarus
schlossen sich menschen heute dem marsch
für gerechtigkeit an zu dem die
demokratiebewegung aufgerufen hatte wir
träumen von demokratie belarus träumen
von freiheit und von recht davon dass
gesetze beachtet werden
wir wollen nicht dass unsere kinder in
diesem gefängnis aufwachsen
schauen sie sich doch um überall stehen
uniformierte hinter stacheldraht
seit sechs wochen wird in belarus
protestiert gegen eine
präsidentschaftswahl deren ergebnis
weder von der eu noch von kanada und
schon gar nicht von den menschen hier
auf der straße anerkannt wird
gommel grodno presst die orte abseits
der hauptstadt werden heute bereits am
frühen abend schauplatz brutaler
festnahmen sommer geworden das
schlimmste und das wichtigste weswegen
wir hier sind es heißt die gewalt mit
gewalt gegen das eigene volk gegen
menschen die einfach ihre meinung sagen
wollen uns da seit juni aus der haft
meldet sich maria kohlessen koffer zu
wort die oppositionsführerin lässt
mitteilen für die freiheit zu kämpfen
lohne sich eine botschaft die
zehntausende in ganz belarus offenbar
bereits verinnerlicht haben
nach dem tod der verfassungsrichterin 5
bader ginsburg ist einer der
einflussreichsten posten in den usa frei
am obersten gericht us-präsident jump
will ihm noch vor den wahlen am dritten
november neu besetzen mit einer frau in
der amerikanischen hauptstadt kamen
zahlreiche menschen zusammen um ihre
trauer über den tod von ruth bader
ginsburg auszudrücken
die 87 jährige galt als kämpferin für
frauenrechte und ikone des liberalen
amerikas rechtsextremismus in der
polizei soll das gezielt
wissenschaftlich untersucht werden oder
wird die polizei damit schon unter
generalverdacht gestellt obwohl diese
woche neue vorwürfe bekannt wurden lehnt
innenminister seehofer eine solche
studie weiter ab stattdessen schlägt er
eine breiter angelegte untersuchung vor
aus berlin thomas reich hat haus zu
jehova bewegt sich nicht trotz der
polizei skandal in hessen
nordrhein-westfalen und
mecklenburg-vorpommern lehnte
innenminister eine bundesweite
untersuchung weiter ab eine studie die
sich ausschließlich mit der polizei und
dem vorwurf eines strukturellen
rassismus innerhalb der polizei
beschäftigt wird es mit mir nicht geben
das wird auch dem problem nicht im
ansatz gerecht in nordrhein westfalen
wurden inzwischen 30 polizisten wegen
äusserungen den rechten chat gruppen
suspendiert in mecklenburg vorpommern am
freitag die wohnungen von zwei beamten
durchsucht seehofer bei will nur eine
studie zu rassismus in der ganzen
gesellschaft
wir wissen sehr viel über rassismus in
der gesellschaft dazu kann man auch
gerne noch mehr wissen und noch mehr
herausfinden
aber es löst eben nicht die frage was
ist bei der polizei los gerade deshalb
wäre eine solche studie sinnvoll
sie löst kein problem aber die sie hilft
voraussetzungen zu schaffen dass wir
gemeinsam agieren können derweil weitet
sich die debatte aus unter dem hashtag
danke polizeiberichten twitter user über
schlechte erfahrungen mit der polizei
darunter auch die stellvertretende
parteivorsitzende der linken
die spd-innenminister drohen nun
notfalls auch allein mit einer studie
voranzugehen
ich denke ja so schon auch wichtig
polizistinnen und polizisten sind träger
staatlicher gewalt dass wir hier nochmal
genauer hingucken und die fälle mehren
sich
alt und deswegen sollte man schon jetzt
tätig werden und so wächst der druck auf
ost seehofer die frage zu klären was
hinter den extremistischen vorfällen
steckt es könnte kitas oder
krankenhäuser treffen im öffentlichen
dienst drohen ab dienstag warnstreiks
auch die zweite tarifrunde für die
beschäftigten von bund und kommunen
blieb ohne ergebnis
verdi und der deutsche beamtenbund
fordern 4,8 prozent höhere löhne
monatlich jedoch mindestens 150 euro
mehr und damit zur wohnanlage in
deutschland da geht die zahl der
neuinfektionen weiter nach oben im
schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich laut johns hopkins
universität täglich 1730 menschen neu
angesteckt gestern waren es noch 1 1640
sehr viel angespannter ist die situation
in großbritannien seit gestern gab es
dort laut johns hopkins universität mehr
als 4400 neuinfektionen fast 42.000
menschen sind in verbindung mit dem
virus gestorben das sind mehr als in
jedem anderen land europas
der britische gesundheitsminister
schließt jetzt einem 20 corona lockdown
nicht mehr aus allein das freundliches
spätsommerwetter kann nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen in großbritannien wird
das gerede über landesweite strenge
ausgangs beschränkungen immer lauter die
stimmung immer trüber wir stehen als
land an einem scheideweg jeder hat
hierbei eine rolle zu spielen und eine
entscheidung zu treffen entweder alle
befolgen die regeln oder es wird zu
härteren maßnahmen kommt als
entscheidungshilfe drohen ab dem 28
september härtere strafen bei verstößen
gegen die quarantäne regeln für positiv
getestete oder kontaktpersonen die gab
es zwar vorher bereits aber fast 11.000
euro für wiederholungstäter klingt eben
sehr schlagzeilenträchtig und aufschlag
zahlen versteht sich diese regierung
mehr als auf ein landesweit
funktionierendes testsystem wie es
scheint in den zurückliegenden wochen
kam es immer wieder zu engpässen setzt
oder schullehrer konnten sich nicht
testen lassen oder mussten hunderte von
kilometer weit fahren wenn ich der
premierminister wäre würde ich mich für
das chaos beim testen entschuldigen sie
haben es den sommer über versäumt sich
angemessen vorzubereiten
bisher unterliegen vor allem regionen im
norden englands lokalen ausgangs
beschränkungen
doch auch die hauptstadt ist davon
mittlerweile nicht allzu weit entfernt
londons bürgermeister fordert bereits
jetzt pubs und restaurants ab 22 uhr zu
schließen
in berlin haben tausende demonstranten
gefordert die flüchtlinge aus dem
abgebrannten griechischen lager moria
sofort aufzunehmen
zu dem protestzug hatten mehrere
hilfsorganisationen aufgerufen
ihr appell richtet sich vor allem an die
bundesregierung denn viele bundesländer
und kommunen sind bereit geflüchtete
aufzunehmen in griechenland hat sturm
ianus schwere schäden angerichtet
mindestens drei menschen kamen ums leben
mehrere werden noch vermisst
in vielen orten sind die bewohner ohne
strom
heftige regenfälle ließen flüsse über
die ufer treten
auch im landesinneren gab es schwere
überschwemmungen llanos war am freitag
und samstag die griechische westküste
entlang gezogen
im westfälischen münster ist es heute
ein außergewöhnlicher sonntag nach dem
fund zweier weltkriegsbomben wurde ein
teil der innenstadt evakuiert
16.000 menschen mussten ihre wohnungen
und häuser verlassen
die stadt hatte für sie notunterkünfte
eingerichtet stunden später dann großes
aufatmen die kampfmittelexperten konnten
beide fliegerbomben entschärfen
und jetzt bist du dran wo die genau
unter staaten mit tennis nach der
disqualifikation des
weltranglisten-ersten novak djokovic bei
den us open wird der serbe beim
atp-turnier in rom besonders intensiv
beobachtet er tat sich bisher schwerer
als gewohnt auch heute im halbfinale
dass er dennoch glatt in zwei sätzen
gewann
ein emotionaler auftrittes novak
djokovic der mit dem spiel des norwegers
ruth lange zeit probleme hat die nummer
35 der welt wehrt sich trotz verlorenen
ersten satzes erheblich spielt
phasenweise erstklassiges tennis
da kann auch der joker nicht anders
anerkennung für diesen schlag den
entscheidenden abstand verschafft sich
die nummer eins der welt kurz darauf
ruht mit einem leichten fehler
nach zwei stunden 11 minuten sie
djokovic mit 7 zu 5 und 6 zu 3 steht
kurz vor den french open in paris damit
im finale von rom und im ersten
sonntagsspiel des ersten spieltages in
der bundesliga besiegt leipzig mainz mit
3 zu 1 und ist damit tabellenvierter
gemeinsam mit augsburg das deutsche duo
kim behrens und cinja tillmann hat bei
der beachvolleyball europameisterschaft
in lettland den titel knapp verpasst sie
verloren gegen ihre schweizer
gegnerinnen mit 1 2 sätzen großer frust
beim deutschen überraschungs duo trotz
des größten erfolgs der karriere
kim behrens und cinja tillmann im bild
rechts haben im dritten satz des em
finales beim spielstand von 15 zu 14
matchball
die riesenchance für cinja tillmann aber
ihr diagonal ball klauen aus drei
ballwechsel später umgedrehte
verhältnisse nun haben die
schweizerinnen heidrich und bergé dépré
die möglichkeit das spiel zu ihren
gunsten zu entscheiden
und tun das gold geht an das schweizer
duo silber nach großem kampf für behrens
tillmann
und das war der kurze sport wird noch
der blick aufs wetter die kommende woche
beginnt mit sonne zumindest am montag
gibt's blauen himmel nur über schleswig
holstein ziehen ein paar wolken und auch
im äußersten süden gibt es wolkenfelder
aber nur ganz vereinzelt schauer
dabei wird das 19 bis 27 grad warm
am dienstag ändert sich wenig ab
mittwoch wird es unbeständiger und
donnerstag deutlich kühler
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
wartet marietta slomka ob sie morgen
begrüßt sie hier petra gerster wir sagen
tschüss danken für interesse wünschen
noch einen friedlichen sonntag